l'homme d'après Rio doit aussi aimer le
monde tout cet environnement naturel que
nous détruisons régulièrement des
centaines de délégués et des milliers
scientifiques sont réunis pour le Sommet
de la Terre l'événement se termine avec
l'adoption de la Convention cadre des
Nations Unies sur les changements
climatiques la machine est lancée c'est
le coup d'envoi de la conférence des
partis les cops depuis 27 grandes villes
du monde ont accueilli cet événement
la première édition se tient à Berlin
présidé par la ministre de
l'Environnement de l'époque Angela
Merkel la conférence tourne en rond le
Canada campera que les nations
industrialisées ont la responsabilité de
faire davantage il n'y a aucun
engagement ferme pour réduire les gaz à
effet de serre
[Applaudissements]
pour les manifestants il s'agit d'un
échec les ONG parlent d'une occasion
manquée
deux ans plus tard la COP 3 au Japon
marque un tournant avec le protocole de
Kyoto adopté après des nuits de
tractations pour ce professeur de droit
c'est un moment clé c'est la première
fois où on a eu des engagements chiffrés
donc c'est la première fois où vraiment
on a quatre tangible des objectifs
tangibles qui étaient assez contraignant
mais il y a une déception les États-Unis
principal et metteurs de GES ne
ratifient pas le document
Montréal accueille à son tour ce
prestigieux se met la coupe 11 portée
essentiellement sur le fonctionnement du
protocole de Kyoto les mécanismes
n'ayant jamais été adopté jusqu'ici
c'était certainement l'une des
rencontres internationales sur les
changements climatiques les plus
importantes depuis celle de Kyoto sinon
même plus
le protocole de taux et fonctionnel on
qualifie l'événement de succès il reste
moins de 24 heures
si on continue comme ça
c'est l'échec
aquapenague les espoirs étaient grands
mais l'issue n'est pas celle souhaitée
[Musique]
l'adopte formellement l'accord n'est pas
juridiquement contraignant et ne fixe
aucun objectif tangible de son côté le
Canada se fait remarquer d'une façon
très peu flatteuse
lors d'un vote ONG il reçoit le prix
Fossile de l'année pour son inaction
climatique
en 2011 à dürben les négociateurs
s'entendent pour prolonger le protocole
de Kyoto tout juste revenu au pays le
ministre de l'Environnement du
gouvernement Harper annonce que le
Canada l'abandonne les cibles étant
inatteignables
invoquant notre droit reconnu par la loi
de nous retirer officiellement de Kyoto
une décision vivement critiquée par
Stéphane Dion alors dans l'opposition
à la COP 21 c'est un changement de cas
pratical
est accepté 195 pays adopte le premier
accord universel dont l'objectif est de
limiter le réchauffement bien en dessous
de 2 degrés ça va faire une grande
différence pour mes enfants pour des
enfants canadiens c'est le début de la
fin de l'ère des combustible fossiles
mais y a-t-il une alternative au Coop
pourrait-on espérer un meilleur
mécanisme les cubes sont le miroir de la
complexité
des négociations internationales ça a
déjà pris beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'efforts beaucoup de ressources alors
c'est extrêmement compliqué dans la
réalité d'imaginer un fonctionnement qui
serait différent mais encore une fois
Charmel shake le décalage est grand
entre la difficulté des négociations et
l'urgence climatique que tous les
délégués reconnaissent pourtant ici
aimer le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]